I feel like I'm gonna be taking a
beating
71 if you've been here you will know
that this guy has given me two out of
three beatings in the 5-minute games one
of which was posted to the channel
YouTube channel here we go
way leg always up there also with the
bullet games so had speed as well
d4 I got to keep up with this maniac
he's fast he's fast and furious here
okay here we go so let's go with thee
for nice and easy you maintain this pawn
I have a space advantage so what does
that mean that means that I want to be
cautious about giving up let's go
giving up low let's kill trading too
many pieces I don't want to trade too
many pieces I'm already having to think
here why are you having to think Bishop
f4 h3 first Bishop f4 Knight d2 okay no
is there gonna be a problem there might
be a problem let me do this I'm not sure
if it's right I'm gonna give it a shot
though a4 I cannot allow b5 no way no
way I might want to do Bishop f3 and
only then move my knight I'm gonna do
this now do it right now and actually I
think I do well with this move right
here
I think the first time I saw this idea
was in a game I played against Nakamura
on line blitz game I did that movie
through the night to a3 it wasn't from
this exact position but it's just this
idea of avoiding the exchange and then
flushing the night back and then getting
the night back again emphasizing this
idea of space white having a space
advantage here so now I think I'd kick
get that night out of there and then I
think I play Bishop here no not so fast
it's get my knight doing something okay
and I want to once again avoid exchanges
I think am I being too silly with these
this might be really weird but I think
g4 is a move here
g4 extremely committal but I'm gonna do
it
if the bishop goes back it gets trapped
f4 f5 so now a big decision in it has to
run back home because if it goes here I
think f4 and then the knight has to go
to g6 this is very critical big decision
for the bishop and I have a two second
leave and time two second lead which is
not much
ok-ran home definitely ran in home there
now what about f4 f4 Knight back night
here I'm gonna try that it's a little
bit area over here my king is probably
shaking a bit the King is probably
thinking what are you doing this is my
shelter no trades night right here okay
no trades again no trades I want c6
ah man this is gonna come to bite me now
or is it
Bishop f3 and everything is nice and
cozy looking for the cozy positions
Forks I think after I played Bishop f3
everything is under control it's also
creating an extension point for my
knight on c6 and and watching over a
floor so that there's no night pivot to
this square oh man deadly okay I have a
fork though but that Queen is gonna come
out here and drop the hammer on the
position ah man
she's doing it again Queen is overloaded
I happen to watch over the pond and the
bishop mmm okay what do you do time to
regroup here the Queen is also ready to
come out here what a killer what a
killer he's a killer
wait a second grab this knight first and
then land a fork oh oh is this scary or
what
it's scary time scary time I think I
should grab this Knight first let's do
that and if I take this then there's
this what about bishop here
oh wait a second do I get the last laugh
yeah the last laugh did I find an
in-betweener this might be a tweener
right here
don't take that night right away hit it
twice if it goes here then oh oh yeah I
could go there maybe I should have
thrown the fork in first should crunch
the numbers on that one a little bit
more but if night here maybe I could
play f5 f6 shatter this structure let's
try it there bottled up if the knight
moves boom if the knight doesn't move
boom the bishop can't move the bishop
can't move the rook can't move the Queen
can move Knight C 494 tricks on this
diagonal we're neck and neck with time
which is rare usually I'm Way behind
right here grab a pond it's scary I
might want to do it though it's scary
but I might want to do it I might also
want to just let things stay as is how
about pond put yeah let's do this now
there's no pawn push I'm watching over
this square and I think there still AM
NOT I think my opponent is still in the
knot here maybe there's rook up and over
no he has to watch over this tonight
this rook needs to watch over this guy
my bishop wants to play and he's not
playing it rook F 2 and then Bishop out
f6 f6 but I guess the knight could be
making use of this square like maybe
just keeping this structure Oh cashing
in cashing in throwing in the chips oh
it's very scary this can't be right can
it I'm on the knight and f7 this queen
is out of play
f7 is brutal
is my opponent cooked oh wait a second
just grab the knight f7 what's the knock
out here is there a knockout
I'm looking for a knockout I'm not
seeing it though okay let's go here for
starters it seems right she's very
active the pawn is pinned rook takes
Knight is threatened announce not oh
it's very scary oh man
I really just want to oh let's do this
let's do this and now I'm looking to
grab the night and then Bishop here oh
oh
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky Oh was my
opponent nervous I'm nervous oh it's
still there it's still there isn't it is
it still there it's there it's working
out hmm
Bishop check no no no that's okay I
could just
okay this pawn is pinned that's the idea
here it's pinned
it's a pinned pun it's a pinned pani
there's also deadly fork on c6 how'd I
miss that oh I missed that move why'd
you miss that move there no I didn't I
guess at the end of it I get a rookie ah
I didn't calculate that though I
definitely didn't calculate that don't
start thinking that I calculated that I
didn't do that oh there goes d6 palms
are falling the king is cut off I want
this pun my bishop is wonderful he's
really happy about having this um this
outpost things are clean things are
clean here time time time time come on
King play come on King come on King
check
so more checks another check okay more
checks uh-oh looking for mates tricky
mates tricky mates looking for me
got the pawn this is a one game don't
slip up now
don't you dare block defense got it now
but not without having my heart skip a
couple beats and it was skipping beats
here we go push push even if the rook
takes the bishop push here we go ten
seconds
oh no steal me do we have it yes finally
good game
always a good game oh man
it's back up that got crazy a lot of
miscalculation right there oh wow
wild stuff right here Benoni the old
Benoni defense huh
jeez okay that got violent that got
violent right there okay well I wonder
if there was an earlier Knight move that
could be played here like at this point
actually scratch that and I can't play
here right now but what about at this
point
instead the rook move is there Bishop
here and then Knight there or something
I don't know something like that comes
to mind but alright my knight pivots
about there's a lot of i sidestepped a
lot on my end the exchanges again a
five-night comes back Knight goes there
no no no no I don't want to trade hit
the rook and then very I think it's a
really turns out to be a very forcing
line right here avoid it again pawn push
and now this boom
Wow I really don't know who stands
better I know Black is up upon my
kingside is compromised and but it's
very uncoordinated on the black side
like right here how exactly do you
assess this position it's not clear to
me it really isn't again for the reasons
I already mentioned that my king not
being too safe here and mmm well I guess
that's the main thing I guess there's
there's some value here in having a pawn
on f5 being able to play f6 so kind of a
viewing this pawn is maybe being worth a
little bit more than just a point and I
guess it is kind of well yeah I guess
there is compensation right for being
down upon here but yeah actually my
opponent
breaks free here and now it's three
pawns for the piece I was feeling pretty
good right here Bishop d5 and then this
is this is turning out isn't it this is
i back my queen up by the way cuz i
wanted to take the knight and then
immediately play that Bishop h6 move
after rook there I should have just
played a fork boom I should have been
looking to that I mean at the end of it
I guess it's still working out all right
but I did not calculate all that no way
I totally missed the Queen takes b2
Queen takes B - so where's there
improvement maybe on the on the black
side then is this just now the right
idea to be good running with here taking
that pie it seems as though that's what
black is needing to do just to free up
the position because it really is
bottled up the knight can't even pivot
this is a weak point but how does the
knight make use of it I'm not so sure
so and I don't know is there something
even before maybe like the Queen move Oh
actually how about this is there
something with just a pond push I wonder
if this could maybe turn the tables a
little bit I really don't know I'm not
able to really offer a whole lot with
this other than to say that it just
really turned out to be a really wacky
game a really a lot of forcing moves
going on a lot of I followed a couple
principles many are a principle many in
many instances in this game the avoiding
exchanges when you're the side that has
a space advantage but yeah a lot of it
was forced and right here I guess okay
instead the rook left I think something
like is king to f8 the move here or
something might it be the case that the
king needs to move to f8 so as to not
allow rook takes Knight pawn takes in
Bishop h6 maybe is there a better spot
for this rook somehow oh how about this
rook here I wonder if that's a move yeah
maybe rip to e5 is a better choice I
wonder okay I can't say for certain but
definitely good game I could say that
for certain